The Eloquent Peasant.
It's some sort of ancient document
from old Egyptian times.
It's gone.
It's a mystery. We like mysteries.
What's happening?
These characters seem like
they're from The Wizard of Oz.
So you'll help us find the Wizard?
And maybe some antacid?
My stomach is a little iffy.
Woah.
Maybe it's some sort of clue.
Look.
We're dealing with a ghost.
Rad.
Please just tell me where I am.
There's a ghost. He's releasing
fictional characters into our world
to help us solve a mystery.
Wanna see the big picture?
Look at things from a different angle.
Woah.
Hey, buddy.
How about getting me outta here?
The Mouse and the Motorcycle.
Meet Rainbow.
She can shapeshift into different people.
I'm Wilbur, and I'm terrific.
Right, Charlotte?
We have to hurry.
We can't give up.
It's brave young people like you
that make the world a better place.
-Did you guys finish reading the book?
-Loved it.
-Me too, the ending--
-I’m not finished yet!
No spoilers please.
Whoo!